deux semaines après son lancement le
nouvel an chinois prend fin ce weekend
et donc dans les Yvelines à
Triel-sur-Seine on vous donne
rendez-vous place Philippe Prévost pour
faire la fête à l'initiative de cette
soirée l'association dragon bleu
Frédéric pinlet donc vous êtes le
président donc ça commence dès 17h et en
fait il va y avoir un défilé de Lyon et
de dragon tout à fait papi
on va lâcher des lapins non c'est
l'année du Lapin c'est formidable donc
j'espère effectivement que le public ne
va pas nous poser un lapin et qui sera
aussi nombreux que l'an passé chez merci
pour la blague je suis pris c'est la
deuxième édition donc cette année ça
avait bien fonctionné l'année dernière
ça fait partie d'un programme culturel
qui est mis en place sur la ville on ne
verra à peu près à toutes les cultures
donc nous ça fait plaisir d'avoir une
association aussi qui est dynamique et
qui est fort de proposition donc
frédéric est venu nous voir un peu deux
ans presque maintenant pour nous exposer
son projet on a accepté ça rentre
parfaitement dans ce qu'on veut
développer et donc ils organisent avec
l'association tout un défilé ça part du
centre commercial les châtelaines pour
se diriger sa traverse toute la ville
avec justement d'animation je pense que
là tu as détaillé plus en détail
justement allez les animations on va y
aller alors un nouvel an chinois c'est
quoi c'est d'abord la rencontre du bas
d'une ville d'une école d'arts martiaux
chinois et des commerçants en fait c'est
le principe même du nouvel an chinois
puisqu'on apporte la prospérité le
nouvel an chinois est là pour apporter
la prospérité chasser les mauvaises
esprits et toute cette culture asiatique
et qui nous fait toujours un peu rêver
et qui est toujours un peu lointaine
donc qu'est-ce qu'on a on a des
créatures qui sont magnifiques qui sont
symboliques comme le dragon qui le
dragon qui est censé justement chasser
les mauvais esprits beaucoup de bruit
les pétards beaucoup de fumées puis la
danse des lions et comme vous le savez
il y a pas de lion en Chine donc c'est
toujours bizarre de penser que pourquoi
il y a la danse du lion en Chine bah
tout simplement parce que sur la route
de les marchands qui arrivaient sur la
route de la soie apporter des lions en
cadeau aux dignitaires chinois et ça
effrayait les enfants dans les villages
qui voyaient ces lions dans les cages et
donc la culture a amené ensuite à ce qui
est la danse du lion pour effrayer aussi
toujours les mauvais les mauvaises
esprits donc
du coup oui
l'année dernière c'était un petit peu un
coup d'essai on était surpris parce que
il y a eu beaucoup de monde qui est venu
de toutes les villes avoisinantes et
aussi des démonstrations d'arts martiaux
parce que le dragon bleu est avant tout
une association sportive qui pratique
régulièrement sur Triel elle propose
donc tout ce qui est Kung Fu tu vas
jouer tout ça exactement alors comme je
vous disais donc il y a une école d'arts
martiaux chinois donc j'ai la chance
l'honneur du présidé depuis 25 ans
maintenant et qui est une école de
kung-fu de tai-chi-chuan de chi kong
tous les arts martiaux de la Chine et
évidemment un entraînement de kung-fu de
tai-chi c'est toujours spectaculaire
c'est toujours beau à regarder on a
toujours même du public qui vient voir
nos cours et de le transformer en
spectacle et ben c'est ce qui va se
passer le soir à partir de 19h place
Philippe Prévost un spectacle qu'on a
voulu cette fois-ci l'Union aussi avec
la compagnie des danseurs idéal c'est à
dire que un vieux rêve que nous
caressons depuis longtemps de mélanger
le kung-fu les arts martiaux et la danse
vous allez l'avoir samedi soir à Triel
c'est un spectacle exceptionnel à ne pas
rater
dans ces festivités
déjà ce qu'a dit Cédric c'est à dire
déjà de découvrir sous un autre angle
une autre culture souvent méconnu des
idées reçues ah non plus finir et là on
voit que la Chine n'est pas du tout ce
qu'on imagine on le verra encore le soir
aussi parce qu'il y aura une soirée
après le spectacle une soirée dansante
avec des musiques que les gens imaginent
même pas ils n'imagine pas que la Chine
puisse être aussi évoluer aujourd'hui
donc il y a toujours une image et le
public qu'est-ce qui vient voir va déjà
pour les enfants de la couleur du bruit
des des choses impressionnantes qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de voir ou alors
qu'on voit sur nos écrans mais les
écrans c'est pas c'est comme les
les jeux de Monsieur là c'est de la
réalité et sur les écrans on n'a pas
l'émotion qu'on a quand on voit le
dragon bleu 18 mètres de long quand même
excusé du peu lumineux qui va défiler
dans la rue c'est extrêmement
impressionnant et alors faut quand même
le souligner c'est que cette année on a
la chance d'avoir un autre pont culturel
avec le Brésil puisqu'on a invité une
trentaine de batucada les batucada 78
qui vont nous accompagner tout le long
du cortège avec une trentaine de
percussions je pense que on va les
entendre de très très loin alors vous
avez parlé de la soirée dansante ce sera
quel style de musique du coup alors
c'est de la musique ultra ultra moderne
très branché et les gens vont découvrir
qu'en Chine on ne s'ennuie pas le soir
quand on sort en discothèque on ne
s'ennuie pas du tout parce que une
ambiance fabuleuse on a la chance
d'avoir ce soir ce soir là DJ Mike qui
va animer toute la soirée et je peux
vous dire que ça va danser donc ça va
pas être comme le restaurant chinois
c'est pas la musique d'ambiance c'est
pas la musique
mais je peux vous dire qu'on a qu'une
envie c'est de bouger dès que ça démarre
et donc au sein de la place il y a aussi
du plusieurs restaurateurs qui vont
proposer
donc actuellement elle est en travaux
justement plus tard il y aura un
restaurant qui ont vu sur la Seine un au
chocolatier embarrasin donc la place le
centre-ville de Triel est entièrement en
train de se modifier de renaître entre
guillemets parce que c'est une ville qui
était très animé dans les années 90
actuellement bon ça a quand même pas mal
puériculté mais là on a donné une
nouvelle dynamique c'est notamment aussi
grâce à Frédéric et aux associations qui
sont nombreuses qui nous proposent
régulièrement des activités qu'on
accepte il y a vraiment c'est ouvert à
tous les entrepreneurs avoir à toutes
les associations qui sont vraiment dans
une démarche constructive avec nous on
est là vraiment là pour vous aider vous
écouter donc là ce qui se passe là c'est
qu'on a donc plusieurs restaurateurs qui
viennent donc toute culture pour le coup
il y a du antillais brésilien libanais
et aussi les Chinois heureusement
maintenant de restauration asiatique
donc on va pouvoir se régaler les
papilles on va dire juste après
justement l'hiver tiens encore en hiver
c'est la première fête c'est la seule
fête d'ailleurs de on Île-de-France qui
se fait en février et là les gens ça
fait longtemps qu'ils sont entre
guillemets pas sortis de chez eux au
mois de janvier c'est toujours un petit
peu délicat on est un peu frileux on
aime bien rester chez soi mais là j'ai
envie de dire on invite tout le monde à
sortir de chez soi pour venir se
réchauffer avec nous autour d'un bon
verre de sacré non c'est pas le sacré
non
mais c'est très fort voilà justement
voilà est-ce que tu pourrais me casser
la table pour donner un exemple
pour attendre tout court ça vous
intéresse Nicolas dandry
facilités et découvrir les autres
cultures notamment la culture chinoise
moi j'ai le souvenir quand j'étais
petite mes parents qui m'a amené dans le
13e arrondissement et de voir
effectivement ces festivités avec des
artistes chinois qui se cachaient sous
ses costumes vraiment flamboyant de
dragon et de Lyon et faire des bah ouais
des acrobaties assez impressionnantes
ouais j'ai une très bon souvenir sur le
nouvel an chinois
c'est vrai que pour nous aussi retourner
beurre dans un projet électronique du
coup tu entends on a des fournisseurs en
Chine et pendant deux semaines ils
arrêtent de travailler vraiment
complètement et du coup c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant de savoir un peu
pourquoi et qu'est-ce que dans leur
culture les incitent à avoir ces deux
semaines de congés intouchables
merci Cédric parlait d'être venu vous
l'avez en armée un dernier mot
rapidement peut-être très rapidement il
va y avoir un feu d'artifice franchement
à ne pas rater à ne pas rater très bien
mais en tout cas merci beaucoup à vous
deux et du coup si vous êtes intéressés
rendez-vous le samedi 4 février à
Triel-sur-Seine dès 17h au châtelaine
puis aux alentours de 19 heures sur la
place Philippe